[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
have fun
have fun dude i am sorry we're late man
and it happens man
she talked about how we're supposed to
be in the car at 6 45 i'm like all right
uh-oh
tell me my dumb ass ain't sitting in the
car waiting until 7 15.
uh-uh okay when i track my wife down 20
minutes later she's stepping up the damn
shower talking about can i help you see
that's crazy right there craig i looked
this woman in the eye i said
[ __ ] you told me 6 45.
you said that yeah i said
[ __ ] then i laid it out but you said
[ __ ] though
hmm you said [ __ ] yeah
you gotta see the fireplace downstairs
in the living room
don't play games man just tell me what
you're doing exactly it's like say what
you mean mean what you say
is that so hard it's like last week man
we going out to dinner right
i'm like where do you want to go she's
like you decide uh-oh i'm like all right
outback steakhouse she's like nah mm-hmm
i'm like straight up chili's she's like
no no daryl i named seven more wrestlers
no
craig no finally said taylor's the place
i know she wants to go in the first
place right right she look at me she
said
if that's where you want to go no she
didn't go right that's where i want to
go
daryl i looked my woman in the eye
socket i told her straight out i just
said it man i said it i said i said i
said
hey guys hey girl how are you doing man
you having a good time are you seeing
the bedroom here we're just looking at a
washing machine look at this machine is
huge
you get a whole bunch of clothes and not
watching this scene baby i'm gonna take
her back up to the kitchen and show her
the dishwasher
hey daryl yeah baby i want a kitchen
island just like the one upstairs
you gonna get it too i love you
i love you i said [ __ ]
if you wanted to go to taylor's just
tell a brother you want to go to taylor
you said that oh hell yeah man i laid it
out right
i said i said i said
i said [ __ ] i'm the man of the house
you you said [ __ ] though you called
your wife a [ __ ]
oh yeah huh daryl where are those guys
so she's like why don't you win a movie
we both like no she didn't after i spent
25 minutes in the goddamn blockbuster
craig
i looked this woman in her optics stands
and i says
[Music]
you said that ain't nothing but a thing
but you said [ __ ] though
yep
oh hey honey uh craig just give me the
neighborhood tour
so then she's like i didn't know we'd be
doing so much walking
nuh-uh i'm like i didn't tell you to
wear those shoes
she said don't raise your voice at me
what
dare roll i look this woman
dead in the windows of her soul
i said
i said
i said